what is going on guys I'm here with the
schmoes know you guys probably know who
they are is Kristian harloff and Marc
Ellis to my sides we just saw the first
full Star Wars trailer at the Star Wars
Celebration in Anaheim California
what were your guys initial reactions
before I say mine I mean look I just
wanted to see it I just wanted to I
wanted to really happen you weren't a
hundred percent confirmed they like to
tease during the panel and then at the
end when they actually the lights went
down and they played it as soon as I saw
that started story or crash I was like
this is the world I want to be in my
first reaction was nerd tears and I lost
my mind I couldn't speak I'm gonna show
it again because I want to actually take
it in and learn more about it like Marc
said you see the fact they had loops
voiceover oh you find the whole thing
and tied it with both Jedi voiceover and
now force awakens dialogue amazing yeah
I mean I loved it guys seriously that
might be the best trailer I've ever seen
and I'm not just saying that as an
extreme fan because not only from a
perspective of showing amazing awesome
it didn't show too much yeah it
didn't spoil too much it didn't show
things that we don't need to know let's
save some surprises let's have fun let's
not just constantly have everything
given to us that's you know it's great
to see a trailer that gets you excited
that doesn't show you all that stuff and
my god seeing Han Solo holy man I'm
telling you
you said nerd tears tears streaming down
my face I had nerd every I had nerd
shadowboxing I was actually laughing a
lot especially when they were first
playing the trailer I just started
laughing I was so excited like oh my god
that's the starters for that's a crash
next wing all this cool stuff when you
break down the actual trailer it was
like
the lineage of the force because we got
to see Darth Vader we got to see a
release we got to see his shell got to
see Luke talking about the what the
forces meant to the Skywalker's over the
years so that's definitely gonna be a
huge factor in this news story and
seeing Darth Vader's shell I just want
to know what that means it's like what
does that have to do with the force
awakening and seeing it I have guesses I
have guessed as speculation speculations
with the schmoes but yeah the Star
Destroyer also the shot of Daisy Ridley
or Rey
yeah helping John boyega up oh right
right right indicates that this is a
very strong woman here a very strong
female character whoa Cameron screaming
whoo you know because Oscar eyes I got
the panel when they asked him what is it
about poet said he's the best pilot
fighter pilots who fighter pilot in the
galaxy right and you went okay so he
definitely thinks that you see him
getting excited yeah that's a character
armor he was lieutenant Pete Mitchell
from from Tom it was such a celebration
and the way that they did the panel
leading up to the tree or how they gave
away just a little bit of character
development without spoiling anything
they really know what they're doing as
far as releasing information to the fans
without letting us know too much yeah
and that's the way I felt too and they
did talk a lot about practical sets the
use of practical effects which we knew
but seeing like bb-8 the droid being
actually rolled out onto stage and being
fully operational because i actually
thought it was cgi at first when i saw
in the trailer not cgi no and and of
course hearing Luke's Luke Skywalker's
voice overseeing r2d2 seeing more shots
of kylo Ren with his lightsaber not
always a cross guard it sometimes it was
an off right the Star Destroyer seeing
Han back saying we're home like that's
the that's the only thing you could have
said could you imagine a better line to
be said again in this trade Julie just
like looking around like it looks like
they're they have recaptured the Falcon
together you're like okay so movie
that's right you not only get the hash
tag and Chewie we're home but you also
get from this video hashtag nerd tears
get me a DeLorean so I can get to
December varieties pop your hashtag
mature we need Lightspeed right now to
get there
but yet lasting Millennium Falcon's
speaking of it more shots of that in
action get a little bit of a JJ Abrams
crash zoom in there zooming in and the
Falcon you know goes through the title
incredible stuff guys I love this
trailer you guys obviously loved it too
any final words in the trailer
what your rating system is like back
when I was a schoolboy so I'm giving
this an A plus plus plus a 100 extra
credit 103 I'll go a 6 sure makes sense
the smells no ratings and for more of
their incredible rating system go to the
YouTube channel go visit the schmoes no
definitely these guys do the same thing
I do and they do it very well
I love the trailer to you guys and thank
you so much as always for watching
definitely subscribe to them youtube.com
slash Mose know and if you like this you
can click right here and get stockman
eyes